.
THANK YOU, PETE.
>>> SO AS YOU CAN SEE BEHIND
PETE THERE, KIDS ARE BACK IN
SCHOOL AROUND THE COUNTRY.
AND WHAT WE DISCUSSED THE ISSUE
OF MASKS IN SCHOOL, IT'S
IMPORTANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT
IT'S A MINORITY, A MINORITY OF
PEOPLE WHO ARE OPPOSED TO MASKS
IN SCHOOLS.
BUT THIS MINORITY IS VOCAL IN
SOME CASES THREATENING,
AGGRESSIVE, EVEN VILE.
NOW THE FLIP SIDE OF THIS, THE
MAJORITY WHO SUPPORT MASKS,
PARENTS AND, YES, STUDENTS SOME
OF WHOM ARE JUST FED UP WITH THE
AGGRESSIVE MINORITY.
CASE IN POINT HERE, IN THIS
PH
PHOTO WHICH HAS GONE VIRAL A
14-YEAR-OLD STUDENT IS GIVING A
ONE-FINGERED SALUTE TO ANTI-MASK
PROTESTERS OUTSIDE HER SCHOOL.
AND THAT SALUTER THERE AS WE
SHOULD SAY FIONA JOINS ME NOW
ALONG WITH HER FINGER AND HER
MOTHER MEGAN DOWNY.
THANK YOU BOTH SO MUCH FOR BEING
WITH US THIS MORNING.
FIONA, WHY DON'T YOU JUST WALK
US THROUGH WHAT HAPPENED ON THE
BUS ON THE WAY TO SCHOOL THAT
DAY.
>> OKAY.
SO, THE PROTESTERS ARE THERE
EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND THEY COME OVER AND THEY JUST
HOLD UP THEIR SIGNS AND FOR ME,
I WAS JUST FED UP.
AND I WAS FILLED WITH ANGER.
AND I JUST DECIDED TO GIVE THEM
THE FINGER BECAUSE I THOUGHT IT
WAS THE BEST THING I COULD DO.
>> SO WHEN YOU DRIVE PAST THEM,
TO GET INTO YOUR SCHOOL, WHAT
ARE THE SIGNS SAY AND HOW DOES
IT MAKE YOU FEEL?
>> THEY SAY LIKE STUFF LIKE
MASKS AREN'T THE CURE, I CAN'T
REMEMBER THE REST.
BUT IT MAKES ME REALLY ANGRY.
I DON'T KNOW, IT MAKES EVERYONE
ELSE ANGRY.
AND WE'RE ALL JUST ANNOYED WITH
IT.
>> YOU KNOW, FOR YOU, WHAT DO
YOU WANT IN TERMS OF BEING AT
SCHOOL?
>> I WANT EVERYONE JUST TO BE
SAFE.
AND IT'S HARD BECAUSE I WAS ON
HYBRID LEARNING FOR SO LONG,
IT'S VERY STRESSFUL AND VERY
HARD.
BUT, I HOPE THAT WE CAN SAY IN
SCHOOL.
>> YOU DELIVERED A CLEAR MESSAGE
TO THEM.
DO YOU THINK THEY SAW THE
MESSAGE YOU DELIVERED?
>> NO BECAUSE THEY CAME TO
SCHOOL YESTERDAY.
BUT I HOPE THAT THINGS WILL
CHANGE.
>> SO, MEGAN, YOU GOT A TEXT
FROM FIONA BASICALLY SAYING,
UM -- WHAT DID THE TEXT SAY?
>> YEAH.
SHE SAID, MOM, I FLIPPED OFF THE
ANTI-MASKERS AND THEY FLIPPED ME
OFF BACK.
AND YOU KNOW, HONESTLY I
UNDERSTOOD HER FRUSTRATION AND
HER ANGER.
IT'S BEEN 18 MONTHS OF THIS
PANDEMIC, WHICH HAS BEEN HARD ON
ALL OF US IN DIFFERENT WAYS BUT
ESPECIALLY I THINK ON
ADOLESCENTS.
AND WE ALL JUST WANT TO GET BACK
TO NORMAL.
AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT UNLESS WE CAN PUT
PUBLIC HEALTH FIRST.
>> IT'S AN ODD PARENTING MOMENT,
RIGHT?
WHEN YOUR CHILD TELLS YOU, HEY,
I THINK I MIGHT HAVE BEEN
PHOTOGRAPHED FLIPPING THE BIRD
TO A BUNCH OF PROTESTERS HERE,
YOU KNOW, WHAT WAS YOUR
REACTION?
>> YEAH.
WELL, WE SHOULD ADD THAT FIONA
HAD NO IDEA THERE WERE CAMERAS
THERE AND I HAD NO IDEA EITHER.
SO WE DID NOT KNOW THIS WAS IN
THE NEWS UNTIL THE NEXT DAY OR
THAT IT WAS EVEN CAPTURED UNTIL
THE NEXT DAY.
BUT, MY INITIAL REACTION WAS,
THEY THINK THEY'RE PROTECTING
YOU.
AND THEN SHE WENT TO CLASS AND
THE DAY WAS REALLY UNEVENTFUL
UNTIL THE NEXT MORNING WHEN IT
STARTED TO GO VIRAL.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY ISSUE WITH
FIONA'S CHOSEN MEANS OF
EXPRESSION?
>> YOU KNOW, WHAT ELSE WAS SHE
SUPPOSED TO DO IN THAT MOMENT?
SHE WAS PRETTY FED UP.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS NOT A
SITUATION WHERE SHE COULD ENGAGE
IN CONSTRUCTIVE DIALOGUE.
YOU KNOW, SHE'S FORCED TO RIDE
THE BUS EVERYDAY TO SCHOOL AND
SEE THESE PEOPLE.
SHE WAS DONE.
SHE EXPRESSED HERSELF.
SO I'M PROUD OF MY DAUGHTER AND
I'M FINE WITH THAT.
>> I'M JUST SMILING BECAUSE IT'S
ONE OF THOSE CHALLENGING
PARENTING MOMENTS WHEN YOU KNOW
YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO SAY THAT'S
NOT SOMETHING YOU'RE SUPPOSED TO
DO BUT YOU'RE WHISPERING TO
YOURSELF, RIGHT ON.
YOU GOT TO BE CAREFUL WITH THAT.
SO FIONA, WHERE DOES THIS GO
FROM HERE, DO YOU THINK, IN THE
COMING DAYS?
ARE THESE PEOPLE -- YOU'RE IN
VERMONT I SHOULD NOTE.
THEY CAN'T BE OUT THERE ALL
WINTER.
IT'S GOING TO GET COLD.
>> I HAVE NO IDEA.
I HAVE HOPE THAT THE SCHOOL CAN
DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
I MEAN, THEY'RE RIGHT OUTSIDE OF
SCHOOL PROPERTY, SO THERE'S
NOTHING THAT I CAN REALLY DO
JUST BESIDES SPREADING THE
MESSAGE TO EVERYONE ELSE TO WEAR
THEIR MASKS.
>> WELL, YOU SPREAD A MESSAGE.
AND I THINK THEY SAW IT AND A
LOT OF PEOPLE ARE SEEING IT AND
I UNDERSTAND YOUR FRUSTRATION
BECAUSE IT IS A MINORITY, THIS
VOCAL MINORITY AGGRESSIVE
PROTESTING MASKS AND SOMETIMES
YOU HAVE TO DELIVER A MESSAGE
BACK.
THANK YONG WITH US
THIS MORNING.
THANK YOU.
>> OF COURSE, THANK YOU.
>> THANK YOU.
>> FIONA AND HER FINGER.
I DON'T -- SHE CLEARLY DID NOT
EXPECT TO BE IN THIS SITUATION,
BUT HERE SHE IS.
>> I KNOW.
AGAIN, I JUST LOVE THE
PARENTING.
>> OF COURSE.
>> CHOICE HERE.
YOU KNOW, MOM, I FLIPPED OFF THE
PROTESTERS.
AND YOU KNOW, HER MOM IS LIKE,
WHAT ELSE IS SHE SUPPOSED TO DO?
AT A PERSON POINT WHAT ELSE ARE
YOU SUPPOSED TO DO?
THE BUS DRIVES PAST THEM EVERY
SINGLE DAY AND FIONA AND HER
FRIENDS WANT TO BE HEALTHY AND
HAVE THIS SCHOOL STAY OPEN.
>> LOOK, NONE OF US WANT OUR
KIDS FLIPPING PEOPLE OFF.
ON OCCASION MAYBE THERE'S AN
EXCEPTION TO THE RULE.
>> BE SELECTIVE.
CHOOSE THE RIGHT -- MAKE GOOD
CHOICES IS WHAT I ALWAYS SAY TO
MY KIDS ABOUT WHEN Y